[Music]
you may have noticed we're always
looking for ways to innovate on this
show we like to be on the cutting edge
so we've come up with a way you can
watch the show from home
and be a member of our studio audience
simultaneously that's right using an
incredible webcam technology developed
in 2007
which is used primarily by the elderly
to see their grandchildren the viewer
can be a part of our studio audience
without
leaving home okay we have a laptop right
there and uh our test here is our
warm-up comedian jimmy pardo
hey conan
hi jimmy hey conan how are you fantastic
jimmy uh tell us you're the first one to
try this uh experiment what's it like uh
is it a thrill it looks like a water
painting
okay somebody water colored you you look
uh blurry no i'm that way in real life
i'm very sickly jimmy uh let us know
that let's see the view from jimmy's
point of view this is what oh
wow okay
what a shitty way to see our show
if you think you might be interested in
attending the show via webcam
i invite you to submit a video
explaining why you're the perfect choice
there's just one rule the video can't be
longer than 10 seconds all right i don't
have a lot of time to look at this crap
so it's going to be 10 seconds long
we will pick our five favorites and then
we'll show them on the show and then
we'll let people vote for the winner
online and the winner gets to experience
this great point of view of our show
show it again there alan yeah wow
that's exciting look at that
so remember 10 seconds so your video
could be something like this
pick me pick me pick me pick me pick me
pick me pick me pick me pick me pick me
pick me pick me pick me pick me pick me
pick me pick me me
or
something like this
pick me
either way
post your videos to teamcoco.com
audience plus one this is exciting stuff
[Applause]